hello and welcome back to the cheeky
science show in this video we're going
to look at what is neurodegeneration so
during the generation is a huge topic
one which affects many of us or people
that we know and also one that's still
being heavily researched and there's
still much that we're trying to
understand but to break it down in to a
short video I'm gonna split up into four
different sections firstly I'll give you
a definition of neurodegeneration then
I'll introduce you to the two major
types of neurodegeneration outside mr.
C's and Parkinson's disease then we'll
look at what are the causes of neuro
degeneration and lastly we'll look at
where we act currently with research and
we'll be still got left to uncover so
how can i summarize nearly a generation
in a sentence so to give a definition
neuro degeneration is the progressive
loss of the structure or function or
both of neurons and even the death of
neurons over time so it's pretty much
progressive disease which is why we see
the symptoms in people who are much
older and as why aging is one of the
major causes for newer generation and so
neuro degeneration encompasses a diverse
range of different disorders with their
own range of symptoms obviously the most
common one that people think of or
associate with new generation is loss of
memory so neurodegenerative seasons are
now common in society but the most
common of these is outside this disease
currently 47 million people are
predicted to have Alzheimer's disease
but by 2050 there's number is expected
to rise to 135 million people and with
the cost per person for treatments being
$30,000 this can toll up to a total of
four trillion dollars by 2050 huge
amounts of money so Alzheimer's disease
and the progressive decline of memory
which ultimately results in the loss of
daily function and death but is
characterized by the presence of amyloid
beta plaques and neurofibrillary tangles
and so these are protein aggregates that
i've accumulates absolutely or inside
cells and the causes for
outside mrs. could be familiar there
could be a genetic inheritance of
mutations in certain genes that
predispose a person to getting the
disease or it could be sporadic for
which there are many different reasons
that we aren't entirely starting off at
the moment as to what is causing the
disease to start and initiate and so you
can see in this figure the effect that's
having Alzheimer's has in the brain you
see the loss of neurons and the loss of
matter in the brain and in particular an
area that is targeted in outside the
disease seems to be the hippocampus why
this is the case why the hippocampus is
more fun with pool than other areas of
the brain isn't quite fully understood
yet but this is what we can observe at
the moment and so the second most common
neurodegenerative disease is Parkinson's
disease and so unlike Alzheimer's
disease that's characterized by the
presence of aggregates of amyloid beta
and towel Parkinson's disease is
characterized by the presence of Lewy
bodies and the symptoms that result from
Parkinson's disease include things like
rigidity arresting tremor and these all
defects and the production of movement
and part of the explanation for this is
the localization of what the disease
causes damage in the brain and so part
of this damage is the loss of dopamine
which is the neurotransmitter that
transmits the signals between the
neurons and the rage of the brain called
the basal ganglia and to be more precise
this is in the striatum and the
substantia [ __ ] pars compacta as you
can see here
alright so slightly already mentioned
this but what are the actual causes of
neuro degeneration so you can split the
causes into two main categories so you
have familial causes and so this is when
there are genetic mutations where
somebody is more likely to have the
disease because of this mutation
alternatively the other cause is
sporadic
there's no apparent reason as far as
we're aware as to why that person would
get the disease this could be due to
their lifestyle could be environmental
factors but also genetic factors and
slight genetic mutations that aren't
particular
the genes of main knowledge but in other
genes that constant kind of unknown ways
at the moment to trigger this disease
somehow from to happen what I'm trying
to say is that could be mutations in
unexpected genes or genes that we didn't
think would be causing the condition or
mutations that would any present with
other mutations in different genes can
cause and effects that makes any sense
but regardless if we consider it to be
familial or sporadic the key questions
we want to need answer to you are how
can we prevent the disease from
initiating and progressing to further
damage and say how can we actually cure
it and so if we're going to be able to
cure these diseases we need to
understand what causes that the C's in
the first days and so a big clue comes
from the genes that are mutated in the
familial conditions so in outside mr.
C's we can see mutations and patients in
the gene a PP which encodes the amyloid
beta protein which is the aggregate I
mentioned earlier there were also other
genes so we have apoe4 and personal in 1
and 2 and so understanding the function
of the different genes that have
mutations could help us to understand
what causes the disease in the first
place
and then to come up with rational
solutions and target treatment and so we
can say the same about Parkinson's
disease so what are the proteins that
are found in these Lewy bodies is alpha
synuclein and this protein is one of the
proteins that gets cosmic genetic
mutations that have seen in familiar
types of the disease and it is currently
thought that the mutations caused the
protein to be more likely to aggregate
and so this could be an explanation as
to how the disease starts in the first
place however it's a sporadic diseases
that can often be more interesting as
often sporadic cases are things that we
think that we can prevent but that's not
always the case however there are
currently some kind of hot topics in
terms of the causes of sporadic cases of
neurodegeneration and so these include
things like inflammation how that
happens is unclear at the moment there
are things such as how much sleep you
get
the glymphatic system is a system in the
brain that's kind of cleaned up the
brain and this is the process that
definitely increases when you sleep and
say having mostly allows the brain to
clear out potential aggregates that
could be triggering and causing the
symptoms of the diseases the last
thoughts I'll pick up the minutes is the
microbiome and how bacteria could
actually be triggering the disease and
say one interesting article that came
out early this year was about gum
disease and the link between that and
out-science disease so yeah be brushin
tonight I will be but my point is is
that those those four exciting research
that's currently being undertaken to
understand neuro degeneration in
particular because it's going to affect
so many of us and say by understanding
the diseases and the causes we can
better design rationale treatments and
so the key thing with neuro degeneration
is you see MIT accumulates
bad but also the loss of kids say we
accumulate these aggregates and then we
leaves neurons and one key emerging
feature amongst all neurodegenerative
diseases seems to be protein aggregation
and so finding ways to prevent or to
break down these aggregates is one way
we could treat the diseases in the
future because at the moment there are
new cures but with current research we
are heading in the right direction so I
hope that this was a good introduction
to BOTS neuro degeneration is and where
we are currently in science